ryan lochte that story just took over
yeah yeah at the NV olympics bit of a
shame cuz all these amazing athletes do
these amazing things and this one guy
sort of gets obvious now and yeah yeah
and it men
the fallout for Ryan Lochte continues
after he fabricated the story about a
robbery a story that he told the real
police well here's the latest because
there's been a lot of fallout from it
today speedo the bathing suit company
announced that they are ending their
endorsement deal with Ryan Lochte and
you got it that's a tough break yeah it
is really tough hey Conan yes sir
oh this mean speedo is looking for fresh
new American face yes sir
probably they are probably looking for
another young handsome athlete
yes great when I do I stop I'm guessing
you just said when do I start
sir I'm not in charge of that decision
but I think they're looking for someone
like Ryan Lochte a world-class swimmer
to showcase speedo swimsuits something
like this
[Applause]
that's fine sir but I think you're
probably they're probably gonna go for
someone who's been training as a swimmer
their whole life I just think that's the
way they're gonna go you mean someone
with moves like this
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
so please please stop doing that okay I
can also do the backboard
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you